obviously there's been a lot of terrific
advertisement for your show and you saw
a billboard of yours that was this on
the subway it was oh my station yes
somebody sent it to me like tweeted me a
photo and it had been defaced and so
this is what someone did to your photo
now you know lounging arm tattoo yeah
man I think first of all I think you got
off easy with this I really did an
obvious thing that could have happened
that they didn't know which I'm thrilled
yeah but I honestly when I saw that I I
was like I have arrived yeah like for a
vandal to take the time to deface me
right I felt really like I've been
noticed we had an idea once years ago on
the late-night show where we wanted to
do Murr this Andy we wanted to take put
up pictures of me where I was that were
intentionally me going out of my way
like saying watch Conan and me going
like yeah watch the show where it was
obvious very clearly how you could draw
a one simple piece of anatomy and
humiliate me and just see how many
people around town picked up on it but
we never did never do we never have it
feel like the time is now no no it's too
late well those things cost money we're
not spending money on that okay I can
loan you like the $40 it's gonna cost to
mock up one post we looked into it it's
50 and that's just too much
you